Michigan is the tenth state to legalize
recreational pot it's now been six years
Faith's now have retail stores like this
one where these people sell stuff that a
few years ago would get you thrown into
jail for by this is the store in
California just like a normal business
though for years experts warn that this
would lead to disaster it's illegal for
a reason and it should stay that way
opponents say the law will increase
crime they said if we if you do this if
you allow this there's gonna be more
crime and everybody getting high
definitely not what we've seen of course
marijuana store workers praised
legalization but maybe other people see
the problems are horrible things
happening nope
nothing nope no horrible things that I
know of there were all these predictions
of disaster and do you see any disasters
seems pretty alright to me I live in
downtown Los Angeles there's a
dispensary around the corner from my
house and it's actually probably cleaned
up the corner why would it clean up the
corner they have a lot of security so
they really pay attention to who's on
the sidewalk who's interacting with
their customers they're actually pretty
much a class act of course there are
some problems my friends just cannot
cont to just stoned out I can't even
concentrate on school but that also
happened before legalization researchers
found more teenagers said it was easier
to buy illegal marijuana than beer it's
been around on the streets being used
anyways it's not like it's any more
difficult or easier now the entire
nation of Canada legalized recently the
first legal receipt
the disaster you predicted hasn't
happened I think it has happened
Paul jabal is a drug warrior who served
in both the Clinton and Bush
administration's before legalization he
told me changing the law would lead to
disaster
we know statistically the drug usage
numbers are gonna skyrocket he hasn't
changed his mind the numbers are clear
Colorado youth have an 85 percent higher
marijuana use rate than the rest of the
country really surveys we found show
teen use did not increase you get this
from some prosecutor who wants to lock
people up but they're doing the Journal
of Medicine says the proportion of high
school and middle school students who
reported using marijuana dropped
yeah these studies have some major
issues with them they're not looking at
Denver or El Paso counties they look at
the overall population ice true trust a
New England Journal more than some DEA
you file well it's not it's actual
research this is your brain on drugs
Americans have long been told that
marijuana does scary things to people
under the influence of the drug he
killed his entire family with an AK in
reality marijuana rarely leads to
violence but what if people drive
Wellstone
[Applause]
[Music]
hot driving fatalities in Colorado up a
hundred and fifty one percent but that
statistic is misleading the active
chemical in weed stays in people's
system for weeks so some of those people
may not have been high when driving but
Colorado police say that cannabis
involved driving deaths are up we want
to make the problem smaller America once
tried making its drinking problem
smaller by banning alcohol that like the
drug war created organized crime and
much more violence prohibition hasn't
worked just because something doesn't
work doesn't mean that we end it you
know poverty for example no it doesn't
mean we quit but at some point when it's
doing more harm than good well didn't we
quit no because then we give up and
that's not American America did
eventually give up on alcohol
prohibition the era was back after 13
years what's I'm an adult this is my
body it shouldn't it be my choice what I
if I want to poison myself no and yet
today for the first time surveys show
that most Americans say marijuana should
be legal New York and New Jersey are
likely to legalize su so far letting
adults make their own decisions about
what to put in their own bodies it's
been working out pretty well